halloommen meine Damen und Herren ich
spiele heute endlich mal wieder clash of
Clans ja kenn glaube ich jeder BR nicht
erklären wir befinden uns hier oh nein
es sind eine Menge Leute gestorben aber
wir kriegen
Elixier hier Elixier wir Gold
1224 ich bin reich checkerer 40 ist am
Start ich bin sogar schon Level 3 unser
Dorf sieht allerdings noch immer im
Vergleich zu dem was wir hier bauen
können ziemlich erbärmlich was ist denn
das clanburg 100000 brauch ich dafür ich
würde allerdings sagen da meine
kampfarbeiter hier alle schon am Start
sind und vor allem auch ich zwei von
zwei verfügbare Bauarbeiter habe werde
ich erstmal das
[Musik]
4000 die Goldmine die wird ein bisschen
höher geschraubt und mein Goldlager auch
da wir jetzt allerdings kein Bauarbeiter
mehr haben und die erstmal für 50
Sekunden braucht dafür anscheinend nur
ich würde sagen wir nutzen die Zeit wo
die da mal so ein bisschen was upgraden
und gehen in den
Kampf s ja auch alle tot ich würde sagen
ich hau meine 20 Leute direkt einfach
mal hier vorne
rauf der riesenarmee
oh
oh oh nein ich
verliere vielleicht sollte ich ein
bisschen taktischer Vorgehen ach guck
mal die Goldmine ist fertig Goldmine
Level 2 nice und wir wieder ein
Bauarbeiter das heißt ich würde sagen
mein elixirammler wird auch noch mal
geupgradet das dauert jetzt auch noch
mal eine Minute in der Zeit mache ich
einen neuen Kampf dafür brauche ich
allerdings erstm ein paar neue Truppen
die ich jetzt ausbilde das ganze dauert
jetzt auch erstmal wieder ein bisschen
nämlich 2 Minuten und in der Zeit kann
ich euch jetzt mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen was erzählen denn ich spiele
nicht ohne Grund gerade clash of Clans
alle unter euch dieash selber schon
spielen und das Spiel ein bisschen
kennen wissen dass regelmäßig neue
Features Updates und vor allem Events
mit dazu kommen und ich bin Teil vom
neuen Event Clash for nature aber was
ist das genau der Clash for nature
findet vom 27 November bis 10 dezember
statt und in dieser Zeit habt ihr also
du die Chance euch euren
lieblingsstreamern lieblings Youtubern
Creator influencern was auch immer
anzuschließen um zusammen für den guten
Zweck etwas zu tun wenn nämlich meinen
QRCode den hier scannt könnt ihr in mein
Team kommen und mit mir gemeinsam Gold
sammeln was wir dann für unser Team se
sammeln und für den guten Zweck sammeln
wie oft soll ich noch sammeln sagen und
dabei kann jeder mitmachen also es ist
komplett egal ob ihr clash of nie
gespielt habt oder schon lange Jahre mit
am Start seid jeder kann mitmachen scant
einfach den QR-Code und wenn ihr mit am
Start seid kriegt ihr sogar noch einen
ingame Boost und ein dekoratives item in
den kommenden Videos werden wir dann
gemeinsam schauen wo wir stehen und wie
viel Gold wir schon gesammelt haben im
Vergleich zu Team trees denn das ist
unser Gegnerteam so oder so spielen wir
aber eigentlich alle in der gleichen
Liga und sammeln einfach nur Geld für
ein guten Zweck bevor ich euch davon
allerdings weitererzähle würde ich sagen
Plan unseren nächsten Angriff der geht
nämlich in 32 1 schon los ich bitte will
eine Truppe oder ach erstmal auswählen
ja hier komm zack zack zack ich setze
erstmal hier ein paar hin hier ein paar
hin und ich setze hier vorne ein paar
hin sodass wir erstmal die ganzen
angriffssachen vom Gegner angreifen die
hier vorne gehen auf die Kanone die
hoffentlich töten können ja hier vorne
gehen auf den Turm den haben sie weg und
wenn Sie jetzt noch die Kanone hier
wegkriegen dann müssten wir den Kampf
eigentlich gewinnen kommt
Jungs
kommt nein ist noch einer tot drei Leute
gegen die Kanone ich glaub wir haben
es und schießt nämlich niemand mehr
ab ganz entspannt während meine Truppen
hier gerade den Kampf für mich gewinnen
kann ich euch auf jeden Fall noch sagen
dass ihr jederzeit in der App im Spiel
clash of Clans das jeweilige Ranking der
Community abchecken könnt und am 10
dezember wird dann geschaut welches Team
vorne liegt und dementsprechend auch wie
viel Geld gespendet wird auch schaut mal
die müssen nur noch das Ding angreifen
dann müssten wir eigentlich durch
[Musik]
sein wo laufen die hin
ach der hat die Burg die ich noch nicht
leisten kann scheiß auf ich hau gleich
einfach mal ein bisschen Kohle ins Spiel
drei Sterne Sieg wir gehen zurück nach
Hause und ihr seht schon oben rechts wir
haben auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was
bekommen hier kriegen wir noch ein
bisschen was und hier kriegen wir noch
ein bisschen was wir können auch noch
ein paar Leute ausbilden ich hauemer
noch ein paar mehr raus so dann hauen
wir noch mal zehn von denen raus ich
habe nämlich aktuell gerade nur 10 sind
wir auf jeden Fall gut ausgestattet wir
können jetzt wahrscheinlich auch das
hier vorne mal verbessern unser Lager
die townhall möchte ich auch mal ganz
gerne noch verbessern mein rathus das
ist nämlich erst auf Level 2 aber es
kostet auch 4000 Münzen da beide meiner
zwei Bauarbeiter jetzt allerdings gerade
erstmal beschäftigt sind der eine für 4
Minuten und der andere sogar für knapp
20 Minuten würde ich sagen schauen wir
jetzt mal in Shop und sehen schon hier
oben dass wir das bauarbeiterpaket haben
das würde ich jetzt auch mal direkt
kaufen denn dann haben wir schon mal
drei Bauarbeiter und je mehr Bauarbeiter
man hat desto schneller kommt man quasi
im Spiel voran 500 Juwelen erhalten
bauarbeiterpaket
erhalten ich bin so am Start diger um
mein Rathaus allerdings upgraden zu
können benötige ich ja wie wir gerade
schon gesehen haben 4000 Münzen und ich
habe nur 2290 bevor jetzt allerdings
meine Goldmiene hier die gerade
abgegradet wird fertig ist und die dann
wieder neues Gold an Start haben etc BP
würde ich sagen gehen wir den kleinen
Umweg
und schauen mal dass wir vielleicht hier
für 119 € uns eine juwelentruhe
kaufen moin Leute ganz kurz Z Info ihr
könnt das ganze Spiel auch ohne in Käufe
spielen ne ihr müsst das hier nicht
machen das was ich hier gerade mache um
gotz will ich ma das nur damit wir m
vank kommen allerdings wo gerade schon
beim Thema Geld sind
100000 werden gespendet und ich meine
klar wir sind alle unterschiedlichen
Teams ne Team trees gegen Team CS aber
schussendlich arbeiten wir alle Hand in
Hand um einfach was Gutes zu tun
deswegen findet ihr alle weiteren Infos
zu den Organisation noch mal unten in
der infobeschreibung also klick das an
es ist gut und übrigens winkt dem
influencer der das meiste Geld mit
seiner Community sammelt auch ein Tesla
als haupgewinn das ist das hier ein Auto
das heißt Leute ladet euch clash of
Clans über meinen QRCode runter scannen
und kommt in meine in mein Team sammelt
Gold mit mir und eventuell können wir
gemeinsam Tesla gewinnen und den würde
ich dann dementsprech natürlich auch
selbstverständlich an Euch verlosen von
daher hat jeder was davon bevor wir
gleich zum letzten Kampf des Videos
kommen habe ich noch kurz mein
Grundstück aufgeräumt und alle Bäume
gefällt ihr könnt ja schon mal in den
Kommentaren raten ob ich den Kampf
gewonnen habe oder nicht und jetzt viel
Spaß wir gehen hier an der Seite rein
und wir gehen hier an der Seite rein und
dann machen wir hier noch mal nein die
gehen direkt hier vorne W ein
abgeschossen soll reingehen nein ich
komme nicht durch oh mein Gott ich Set
jetzt einfach alle hier ein dass S
erstmal auf dieses Ding hier drauf gehen
damit das erstmal wegkommt aber das Ding
ist halt das so ein massenschaden ne
wenn das einmal so ein Teil
rausschleudert wie jetzt gleich so eine
Kanonenkugel das geht dann direkt auf
alle meine Leute oh mein Gott viicht
haben die bevor so ein Ding kommt J okay
drü die Daumen nein diger es leben nur
noch so
wenige das schaffe ich auf gar keinen
Fall die unten sind alle
tot ich muss mit mehr Taktik rangehen
ich w sagen dass das Ganze mit der
Taktik im nächsten Video von meiner
Reihe clash of Clans mit Luca angehen
dementsprechend Freunde wenn ihr Tipps
habt schreibt ger unten die Kommentare
ladet euch clash of Clans runter über
den QR Code hier kommt in mein Team und
dann spielen wir
gemeinsam im nächsten Video noch mal
mehr dazu dann schauen wir uns mal ein
Update an und am 27 November geht's
erstmal los danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]
ciao
not
even